[Music]
foreign
is made from hundreds if not thousands
of letters numbers punctuation marks all
puzzle pieced together
my name is James Cook I am a typewriter
artist
[Applause]
26 year old James Cook is an artist from
Essex England
but he doesn't carry a Sketchbook in
pencils instead he makes every one of
his intricate drawings on a vintage
typewriter I'll feed a paper through the
machine probably eight to nine times
collaging and overlaying lots and lots
of information to recreate skin tones
I'll use the at symbol because it has
quite a large surface area brick work is
underscores and capital I's to get the
vertical lines from a distance it could
quite easily be like a print or an
illustration where it's only when the
viewer gradually knees closer and closer
to the image that all of these
individual letters numbers and
punctuation marks are revealed
everyone is drawn to people's eyes so
that's the hardest facial feature to get
right they have to be perfect
something else I will do to add another
layer of complexity to the drawings is
conceal hidden words or phrases for the
viewer to find
[Music]
how long does all this tape
being take something that's A4 size
could take a week There's a picture of
the London Skyline took two months
is that obviously I don't count how many
I did actually try and download a piece
of software which counted the number of
times the Hammers hit the page but it
stopped working after fifty thousand so
I have no idea James's favorite
typewriters all have portable cases so
he can pack them up and tape Outdoors
a funny look to begin with they'll be
like what's this guy doing with this
typewriter on his lap why is he writing
a letter in the middle of London
but then as they Edge closer they they
suddenly realize oh no this this is he's
making a drawing and James's shelves are
filling up I've got about 63 typewriters
and Counting and I've been very lucky
because the general public have seen
what I do with them they see it as a way
of giving these machines a second life
otherwise they would be sitting around
collecting dust I've become a collector
by accident I didn't plan to have all of
these they all have their own different
personalities to them they'll kind of
work in different ways they have
different sounds different feeling
behind the keys there's a lot of tap tap
tap all these typewriters make a lot of
noise there's some technology that will
never die that's quite amazing to think
that even though most people generally
don't write with a typewriter anymore
they still have a purpose is it fair to
say you really love typewriters uh
oh I'm not gonna I'm not I'm whoa do I
say yes to that I like drawing more than
typewriters that's so
[Music]